hey 42 here for the most part it's
pretty good being alive
there are tacos videos of monkeys cheap
air travel and many exciting hats to
choose from but it all flushes by very
quickly and you barely gets a moment to
enjoy it between sleeping school work
waiting for Windows tend to install and
torrenting Star Wars and before you know
it it's all over and you're floating
away from your body wondering what you
could have achieved if you'd skipped
season 6 of How I Met Your Mother
I've got out to sit in the sunshine for
a while so how do we hold on for longer
can we prolong the inevitable end
because we're just not ready yet I mean
come on I've got tickets to see Cirque
du Soleil next week and I just bought a
free for one toothpaste deal can Cubans
delay death because in the words of the
great Terry Pratchett inside every old
person is a young person wondering what
happened
if you switch on the news for a few
minutes you might feel like there is
death and destruction lurking around
every corner and that you'll be lucky to
make it to lunchtime but the truth is
overall we are living longer than ever
if you look back to 200 years ago life
expectancy in almost every country
except the UK was below 40 and as low as
25 in some of apakah and Asia since then
it has increased with strange regularity
on average we have gained one year of
life span for every five years that's
have passed there are obviously some
dips after the world wars as well as a
Spanish flu epidemic in the early 20th
century but we have arrived today after
global average of 71 years women outlive
men by about 4 to 5 years but we're
still not sure why this is if it was
down to less manual work you'd expect
that there would be less of a difference
now that we all sit on beanbag staring
into spreadsheets for eight hours a day
but it's unchanged and if it's the extra
cigarettes beer and chicken wings that
men supposedly consume then why does the
same difference
in eighth a Korean scientist named Han
Nam Park has suggested it could be the
effects of testosterone citing a study
that showed eunuchs that's men who have
had their testicles removed lived
noticeably longer than other men um I
think I'm fine with the five year
difference actually it's diet and
medicine that keep pushing our life
expectancy Europe although there must be
some upper limit to how long a human can
live there have been no signs that we
have reached it yet we will eventually
arrive at a 100 year average and
probably keep going soon we're going to
get pretty bored of the sight of one
another heart disease and strokes are by
far our biggest killers but as the
treatments and care for these improve we
are getting better at fighting them both
are linked to high blood pressure and
high cholesterol so doctors can help
patients with a range of lifestyle
changes and medications to lower their
risk just one hundred years ago these
killers were a lot less common not
because people were leading healthier
lives far from it statistics actually
show that we eat healthier now even with
the prevalence of fast food but it was
that people were dying much earlier from
infectious diseases such as pneumonia
flu and tuberculosis now that's what
happens when your national cures are
mainly whiskey cigarettes SIA and radium
they weren't glowing with health they
were simply pumped full of radiation
aside from combating disease we have
spent many years looking into slowing
down the aging process itself we're not
clear on exactly why we age but a fairly
common theory is that over time your DNA
loses its ability to withstand damage
and to repair itself making mutations
more likely and these aren't the cool
mutations that give you laser eyes and
teleportation these are just your cells
ceasing to function in the way you need
them to your body renews itself almost
perfect between the ages of about 20 to
35 and after that your cells begin to
lose interest and start thinking about
retiring maybe to go sit by a nice beach
somewhere down by your kidneys
so one way to combat this is to poke
around in a DNA and find the
troublemakers the book Institute found
238 genes that could be deleted and
increased a lifespan of yeast and you
might be thinking Oh yeast whoop-dee-doo
I always wanted a mortal bread but your
DNA shares much more in common with a
slice of toast and you might think
that's right when you eat your lovely
buttery toast in the morning you're
chomping down on your DNA cousin you
monster they managed to get a massive
60% increase in the lifespan of these
yeast strains and are now looking to
test this out a little higher up the
evolutionary chain the key gene for this
60% jump is called el OS 1 which is
linked to a master switch that is
associated with calorie restriction it's
long been thoughts that calorie
restriction has been linked with longer
lives after all humans aren't designed
to gorge ourselves every day on burgers
an ever so deliciously flaky creamy melt
in your mouth pastries yeah I know it's
difficult but humans are
hunter-gatherers at heart our body has
evolved to go days without eating at all
which was common for our prehistoric
ancestors interestingly during the Irish
potato famine national life expectancy
actually rose from 40 years to 50 going
against every expectation now before you
spit out your ramen and throw away your
banana you're not supposed to starve
yourself malnutrition has a terrible
impact on your body the key is to walk
that fine line of getting just the
calories you need to survive the
research is still a little vague partly
because no matter how dedicated you are
it's hard to get someone to have that
much self-control for 10 years or so I
mean I've only just mentioned food and
you're already thinking about what's in
your fridge yes that type of Venn
injuries will still be there when this
video is finished please sit back down
experiments on mice that involved just
limiting their food on alternative days
known as intermittent fasting has
resulted in longer living mice and a
reduction in age-related diseases such
as Alzheimer's diabetes and cancer often
just missing a few meals each week it
could work for a few reasons the reduced
energy in your body may mean your core
temperature is slightly lower so your
general metabolism happens little slower
- also less cellular division means
there is less chance for your DNA to
become damaged so if you don't want to
eat less maybe just produce your core
heat by sitting in a bath full of frozen
peas in ice cream I should be a doctor
the metabolism is clearly a big part of
the aging issue but what if we could
just inject ourselves of some magic
serum and magically live for longer well
researchers at Cardiff University we're
investigating type 2 diabetes and they
noticed that patients who took the drug
metformin lived on average 15% longer
than a group of healthy people who
didn't have diabetes and weren't taking
metformin but we're similar in nearly
all of our respects in terms of age
lifestyle favorite game of Thrones
character and so on this is very
surprising because diabetes even when
controlled should shorten your lifespan
it could be because metformin interferes
with a process called glycation this is
a major metabolic process where sugars
attached to proteins but it leaves
behind a thing called advanced glycation
end-products
or AG s ironically this is bad and they
basically gum up your biomolecular
workings like when you got cake in your
keyboard because we are a greedy and
ridiculous species we've actually been
adding a G's to our food typically
things with caramelization like
doughnuts barbecued meat and dark sugar
drinks why does evil have to be so
delicious
our last way of living longer sounds
like it's being ripped from the pages of
some creepy Victorian novel in 2005
Thomas Rando from Stanford University
found that he could rejuvenate older
mice by surgically linking their blood
flow to younger mice
it apparently worked best if there is a
new moon the young mouse is a virgin and
stays of garlic flavored mouse food but
maybe I've been reading too many cheesy
vampire novels this vampiric practice
enabled the stem cells of doddering old
rodents to suddenly become effective
again and begin to repair damaged cells
build new tissue and stop them being so
confused about smartphones Harvard
University biologist Amy wagers looked
into this further and believes it is a
protein called G d/f
11 that is responsible and that this is
what is lost in older mice she managed
to get similar results to ranlo by just
injecting them with this protein but
Rando said that his creepy vampire way
was much more fun and gave him an excuse
to wear a cape and play My Chemical
Romance it full-volume all day however
because this is science recently a team
from cambridge massachusetts claims that
gdf 11 actually increases with age and
acts to inhibit muscle generation so the
complete opposite see this is why
everyone hates you science stop
contradicting yourself but before we
start worrying about adding a few years
to the end of your days you're probably
better off just dealing with the life
you have now so go ask out that girl or
boy that you like find a good book to
read and if you're worried that eating
that box of donuts will save a week of
your existence
why don't you compromise by leaving that
bit in the middle that's where all the
calories are you though thanks for the
view subscribe for more 42
each part of the tree wants to kill you
in a different organizing way the fruits
it grows look like apples smell like
apples and even tastes like apples put
her nuts apples if you think making a
murderer was shocking you ain't seen
nothing yet it's estimated that every
year in Japan hundreds of people are
wrongfully convicted for crimes they
didn't commit